in other nfl news our long national
nightmare is over the antonio brown
helmet grievance 2.0 resolved on sunday
and look at it with the old fred
bolitnikov helmet christians if you're
enjoying on nbcs under sky sports you
see the old two-bar helmet with a little
bit of the little puffing at the ear
they used to have those elephant ear
helmets when i played grade school
football there was one elephant ear
helmet and it was like you you that was
the kiss of death if you got the
elephant you didn't want that i didn't
you didn't want the extra no it looked
it looked like it looked like it was the
50s like what's next a leather helmet so
uh antonio brown has lost the second
helmet just like we thought like hey
he's got a great argument bottom line is
he's not winning right he didn't win it
didn't help him at all the nflpa
reportedly and i i can confirm that this
happened submitted an affidavit
supporting the nfl's position to the
arbitrator when the union's against you
on this you ain't going to win you're
not going to win but he is going to win
chris because now
his new helmet whichever one it may be
is going to come with an endorsement
deal a customized a b helmet and it's
going to be zenith or vices or rydell or
shut and he's going to pick a new helmet
he's going to pick one soon he's going
to get paid to wear it so there's a wind
there's a silver lining a silver and
black lining for antonio brown and all
this definitely a win i mean first off
not shocked that he lost this grievance
at all and the nflpa even though again
they're on the side of the player uh
they're they're gonna protect their
players at all costs protect the players
from themselves that point at some
points too to where they probably didn't
feel comfortable backing the helmet
situation for antonio brown but um i
mean doesn't it have to be shut air
they're they're losing at it they don't
the ones that shine the air advan that's
the thing well the shutter has gotten
tons of free publicity over the last two
weeks and they quit making it ten years
ago no but shuts got a bunch of shots
just like nike when zion williams
exactly they gotta win i mean that right
now they're synonymous with each other a
little bit i just it would make too much
sense a b and then they need another
initial on the helmet to go with it like
the a b
s whatever i don't know whatever it is
but it's certainly yeah he's going to
get paid and that's good don't don't
don't apply to [ __ ] first job you got to
come up with i got to call it the better
helmet
although the abs whatever who knows uh
but the baby
is it's gotta look good right we saw
that in hard knocks last week he had
that helmet on and he went to a teammate
and said this lid is ugly as bleep it's
a little egghead-ish i understand what
he said
those are a little different yeah they
they look like they have like like
buttons on top like every helmet seems
different and they're all convoluted
with holes where there aren't supposed
to be holes and like you can't fin like
some of the logos
are interrupted because it's on holes
like whatever happened to just the old
normal helmet and then i think some of
the players feel that way and they don't
want to wear this thing that's all that
just it it feels like they're wearing
some sort of sculpture on their head
yeah well it looks like a a spacesuit at
times as far as space helmets something
like that you get from nasa but uh
they're designed that way to with with
you know withstand a lot of high impact
situations from all different angles and
uh the players aren't going to win this
one and i didn't expect antonio brandon
bottom line antonio brown makes a scene
raises a stink causes a ruckus and falls
ass backwards into money that's right
that's a great life
is amazing so on top of the 30 million
he's going to get the next two years
from the raiders he's going to get even
more from shut or vices or zenith or
rydell or some helmet manufacturer will
have that information for you as soon as
he makes his decision
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports